hello and welcome to this video playing
funky d okay let's see what we get yeah
I'm just playing some random stuff and
yeah we get the same category felt here
you know slide into somewhat harmless
version this black setup is known since
I'm that famous famous fishing game burn
Bertha's Fisher said Ross at Robert
Byrne not quite sure one of the two
obviously one of the burn brothers so is
he for coming here maybe yeah it's an
active move huh yeah now it's got 96 sir
around the corner him taking on d4 is
probably not working at all and rook e8
that's 96 this is not very comfortable
maybe I began to look over to d7
may I feel like white might have
something here some tactic I know nitey
five or so my position looks somewhat
uncoordinated rook c8 was a somewhat yes
rook c8 was a somewhat I was to relax
angles
okay I cannot take deform and you're
threatening night takes is six yeah I'm
not happy with this but don't quite see
one else ya ever take e five with my
bishop I don't quite see what happens
okay but okay but should be five the
screen da droop t8 rook c8 at the end I
7s hanging okay so I cannot take this
then so if I take you five am I losing
it's not so much that I want the pawn I
want to prevent pieces coming to the six
okay
yeah not happy here but have to hang on
ok so I probably want to move the rook
rook to e1 may be here yeah I know I I
might be in some tactic here but moving
the Queen wasn't possible i think so
whoopsie 7 10 25 unfortunately
we are going to be eight looks like
complete crap but I have no other square
Oh came how to defend this year like I
probably want to go back to be seven
then maybe like Bishop Bishop e7 rope d7
yeah bishop 186 didn't do much anyway
the problem is that there are all kinds
of tactics like on d5 and Knight f6 I
cannot easily move the root line Oh
didn't see that move we should t54 this
is the point here in the first place I
don't get it really you should take and
what's the point we should have six
Queen takes Queen Sierra cod Queen f8
Quincy three maybe
yeah dot that's the phone okay so how do
I continue here Bishop d6 Bishop c5 I
guess let's prevent stuff there is g5
something okay let's do that
check a bishop is very strong
I would like to trap it it would really
nice trip the rupiah time are Nairobi
not possible
check yeah the bee pollen will do the
job check white resides yeah it was a
very bad position for me very very
likely here and 95 it's very shaky a
very shaky position of like yeah the
computer gives gives a clear edge for
white not not surprisingly but ok this
was ok I have to play f6 the computer
prefers rook the one here in this
position yeah we have to go 95 there is
no there is no the most and then try to
hang on here yeah the position is not
losing yet but it is it's very bad of
course it's an exchange my strongly five
bishop is helping a little bit there are
some situations where black can really
fight and this is kind of this kind of
setup like forget the bishop to d4 and
get it fortified with you five but
difficult to do yeah that's it was
probably winning her white or close to
it this wasn't so successful now I'm
hanging on
check yeah it does this just doesn't
work I guess he bills miscalculated
thinking that you can take on f6 and
play Queen CA but I have queen too fa
DSO maybe he was originally intended
this but this is saving the day yeah I
was intended sorry yeah this is just a
fairly simple technical win okay how was
tough and somewhat lucky thanks for
watching